you
it's been just under three weeks since I
uploaded my 10,000 subscribers thank you
video now here we are at the momentous
100 thousand milestone a lot of people
have asked for a behind-the-scenes look
at how I make my videos before we get
started let me just take a moment to
thank all of you amazing people for
sticking with second thought and
supporting the channel I'm also going to
use this video as a Q&A so if you have a
question that I haven't answered by the
end of the video leave me a comment
below and I'll respond to you as quickly
as I can
now on to the main event every second
thought video starts as a simple idea
when something interests me I write it
down on my ever expanding list of video
topics at any given time I have about
two or three months worth of videos to
choose from once I pick the topic I want
to use it's time to research it's
amazing how many scholarly resources you
can find with just a simple Google
search scientific journals and study
reports are my favorite resources
because they provide raw data without
imparting significant bias
I'll take note of the source then
synthesize the information into short
notes before moving on to the next one
once I have enough notes I'll throw in a
dash of my brilliant second thought
brand humor and draft up my script a
couple read-throughs to make sure it
flows nicely then it's time to record
the audio I'm going to let you in on a
big secret you don't need a fancy
recording studio to get decent quality
audio I want to see my studio here it is
my closet all the fabric helps absorb
unwanted noise which is perfect for
recording clean audio as for hardware I
use a zoom h5 recorder with shotgun mic
attachment to make sure I only capture
my voice without any background noise it
usually takes me about 20 minutes to get
everything recorded to my standards from
there I'll head over to my computer to
edit the audio I'll put a link to PC
part vicar comm if you want to see the
exact parts I used in my build but here
are the big points I 760 700 K
superclocked
gtx 1070 16 gigs ddr4 ram and a 500 gig
solid-state drive for the operating
system family they'll be sweet and
battlefield I'm no sound engineer but
I'm very familiar with Adobe Premiere
which is adequate for simple trimming of
audio files I'll take about an hour to
go through and trim out noticeable
breasts and pauses as well as the sound
of muffled crying when I mess up a
sentence for the 15th time once that's
done I'll export it as a high-quality
mp3 and save it for later now I have two
different ways to make the actual video
and it all depends on how proactive I am
in the days leading up to the upload if
I'm good I'll open my script in
Photoshop side-by-side and draw the
assets I'll need for the video before I
even
open after things more often than not
though I'll just draw as I go in that
case I'll have After Effects open with
Photoshop minimized and when I meet a
new character or drawing I'll pull up
Photoshop draw it export it as a PNG
file and import it into After Effects
for drawing I use to walk them into a
stab lift it's nothing fancy I think I
paid about 80 bucks for it but it gets
the job done and it's never giving me
any trouble from there I'll just sit in
my terribly uncomfortable Walmart chair
and edit for about 10 or 12 hours
straight until the video is done and
that's it it's a lot of hard work but
it's so rewarding to finish a video and
know you did a good job
I'll refine my setup when I'm able and
hopefully I'll be able to put out even
better videos in the future again I
couldn't do this without the support of
all your fantastic people your comments
never fail to brighten my day and it's
incredibly rewarding to see our
community grow the way it has together
we'll make second thought one for the
history books remember to ask any
questions you have down below in the
comments thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]